next 10 years or so i would say maybe a
little bit more by which we're gonna
have to develop and treat it like a
decision support system we're gonna
we're gonna
figure out how to play along our you
know smart digital assistant in our in
the car who is going to take
responsibility on what honest conscience
and subconscious level
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hello at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
let's talk about mobility welcome to 20
minute leaders and meet tal cohen
founding partner drive and next gear
ventures
paul is a visionary entrepreneur and
investor and is considered one of the
leading innovation experts in smart
mobility he is the founding partner of
drive tlv israel's leading smart
mobility innovation hub and next gear
ventures
for the past 20 years dr cohen has been
involved with many startups helping to
create companies with billions of
dollars in value
among others he co-founded and headed
click fox inc currently valued at
hundreds of millions of dollars
the company is a global market leader in
providing customer behavior intelligence
software and services to fortune 1000
companies
telco and welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you for joining me from the next
gear and drive to all the offices how
are you
very good very good thanks very much for
uh
for this uh lovely podcast uh michael i
i'm i'm really truly honor uh honored to
have you here because you know we're
gonna be talking about some of my
favorite things automotive
sustainability uh but all in the context
of startups and innovation and tal
you're you're such a prominent figure
and you know both in the israeli but
global ecosystem for for these subjects
exactly with the founding of next gear
and drive tlv uh and i'm just really
excited to hear about you know the
founding story to hear about your
perspective on where the automotive
industry is going we're seeing a lot of
news about it you know in the in the
last especially two three years so tell
me a little bit about yourself and and
initially what got you hooked on the
automotive industry personally
sure sure
thanks very much for the
lovely kind introduction michael i'm not
sure i deserve all these things but
look the
obviously the mobility and automotive
industries
having the this fundamental change and
that's driving a lot of innovation and
startups and talent
and i'm just curious and i like to be
part of this uh disruption
and it's fun to be from some
part of something such dynamic
as this is how i find myself in that
okay i saw many startups are in here in
israel
and so many of them are touching
innovation innovation mobility and just
it was just talking to me and said wow
this is a big challenge that we should
address
were you always passionate about cars
specifically was this you know from a
childhood sort of dream like i know many
kids have you know they dream of
ferraris and those types of cars
was that it
no
no no no i was i was that's not it i was
i was passionate about mechanical things
so about moving things but don't sell
any cars but you know the concept of uh
you know um drive shafts wheels
uh mechanisms processes kind of things
that are you can play with your hands
that's definitely something that was i
was passionate about and you know
putting this around digitize around the
ai that's really made it for me you know
you you're i love how you're bringing me
back to the to the first robotics
competition days uh now exactly how do
you see
the autumn of automotive industry today
where are we at today in terms of the
the industry as a whole you know from a
30 000 feet a bird's eye view
sure sure
um
you know it's a it's it's um
it's really fascinating the snapshot
today michael
you have so many colliding forces but i
think the dominant one
is coming out of a reality that we are
in you know in the coverage reality and
the supply chain reality
and in
a recognition by the industry that
the
the main energy source
for mobility has to change and is
changing from
fossil fuel to electrification mostly
and i think that
that has huge ramification on
how things are moving forward
uh by all means by means of you know the
simple stuff
the fact that you're gonna have more
ev's model but also on the level of risk
and uncertainty the everybody's taking
you know uh
the infrastructure there's a company
with that the
uh uh unknowns with regards to the user
experience of of of those
what could unfold in the next 10 20
years
so there's
those
compounding to a
major question marks about
the
industry in the future
the leadership the winners the losers
and you know it's fascinating to be part
of that
now take me back you know six years a
little bit more than six years to the
founding of dr tlv
followed by the founding of next gear
where are you at in your career and
where is the automotive industry that
sort of
synergized into into you founding these
organizations
yeah so i tell you where i'm coming with
from in this point you know basically
for 20 25 years before that as an
entrepreneurs in in as in
you know person in the academy
i
enjoyed bringing value to big
corporations you know from startup
perspective
and i realized that one of the most
fundamental issues that starps has to
face
is as quickly as possible get some
orientation on their valuable position
like it
so
you know it's good it's good to come up
with your ideas and concepts that can be
bring value but it's
very uh
uh a
necessity basically for the startup to
get as quickly as possible understanding
of where they are standing okay how good
is the solution how valuable is the idea
and what to do in order to change and
make it more valuable so that's from the
startup perspective and from the
corporate perspective when the
atmosphere is getting more competitive
there's more disruption you have more
appetite for innovation you have more
appetite for for things going to become
new so i i know that from both sides and
basically six seven years ago when i uh
really kind of i was actually mostly in
the us come back to israel
and i saw the talent the pool i realized
that there's a tremendous potential in
israel in terms of startups and mobility
but there's also tremendous unknowns and
i saw the unknowns
spread you know to the corporates as
well the people i met the entities i met
really didn't really kind of they were
in awe from the innovation but bringing
it on board it's a different task
altogether so i realized the gap and
that's why you know i proceed the way i
proceeded
now i imagine that you know if you look
at traditional you know b2b sas or
product like growth companies in order
to get their validation you sort of you
know you create a poc you put it out
there and then it's it's pretty cheap
both in terms of time and money to get
validation and seeing you know how
people engage with your product but but
there's an extra added layer of
complexity when it comes to the
automotive industry right why is it so
hard to to get that validation in this
industry
so i think there's a positive side to
that not necessarily hard it's this it's
obviously hard but there's a positive
side of that as well okay
uh
the the automotive industry
is
is an industry that works
you you go into a platform you stick the
key in you press on a button you drive
it works you press the pedal it stops
okay so things are working and working
for
days weeks months years
everything is working so
you know you know if you've been in in
any software type of development you
have bugs
you run a program you find the bugs you
fix it you want to build it fix it
again
you know so traditionally to go 10 20
years back you cannot you cannot have
bugs on mission critical systems like
that and i think
it's it's it's a concept that built
ten thousands of people hundred thousand
people organization
and it's a cultural thing so if you want
to introduce innovation
experiment experiment uh you know on
different type of
versions and reality it's much more
difficult to do it in a classical
environment that is manufacturing
reliability based and valued in a
certain dna of organization you know
right and so how how do the how do these
two organizations sort of work
you know hand in hand with you know when
it comes to to startups in the
automotive space
so first they don't work okay
it's the basic thing is that you have to
assume it's really difficult for this to
work
but
you have to understand that this is the
challenge and once you understand this
is the challenge you actually can find a
way for this to work
okay um and by the way you see the
industry
the organization are struggling
struggling to change okay it's not it's
not an easy task
and
so you have joint ventures you have site
organization you have silos
you have a
you have separate type of entities that
are living in parliament to orthodox or
you know conservative organizations so
you create some structural
facilities
for uh incumbent to fight and to battle
in the new innovation field
against the newcomer so to speak right
and was this something that was you know
relatively trivial for them to do to to
sort of partner and and be open and and
you know be be even cognitively and
resource-wise available to to these
types of partnerships and these types of
experiments as you would call them
because we're talking about incumbents
that are really really big some of them
from very different cultures than ours
so the reality
again i think that uh
it it is trivial on the on the on the
message level it's very difficult on the
execution level right because when you
have things that work for decades
you know it's it's very difficult to to
redirect them it's very difficult to
take in
resources and move it to
a totally different area and kind of
ignore whatever worked for you for the
last 25 years so it's very difficult
there is a way okay there is a way to do
that
and uh and you have to have
you know strong commitment strong
leadership and uh
um and and pull from you know from the
top
but it has to be consistent has to go
through throughout the organization and
and we're fortunate to have that in some
of our partners here in drive and next
year
so we're approaching 2022 we're seeing
headlines every day
about you know what's happening to the
automotive space and i have to tell you
it's confusing and i'm confused
can you make sense for me
how do you see the future of mobility
moving forward given everything given
all the innovation everything that's
going around around us where is this
industry moving
yeah yeah yeah no i mean
i don't know i don't have a crystal ball
but i can give you some some of my
thoughts okay and and
uh so
i really think that
you know the concept of smart mobility
is moving into more sustainable mobility
so i think that the
mobility was
free
to do whatever they want
for the last 100 years in terms of
coming up with new concepts
a
different type of platforms
addressing
needs that are consumer-based needs
i think that we are facing a reality
that is more and more vivid about how we
need to behave as a society in in
so to speak a
sustainable responsible way circularity
uh co2 emissions and and so on and so
forth all the way through from the
manufacturing to the usage and to the
platform
merit
and i think that
we are getting get into more and more by
which we have to live by these
constraints
and the companies and
entities are going to be more successful
to combine those
trends together with us as the society
will be more successful so i think that
if it used to be connected autonomous
shared
you know electrified
i think it's more sustainable now and i
think that it the digitization
is gonna is gonna actually
play into the sustainability and the
progress they're going to build into is
going to play into the understanding of
how we're going to make the next
generation of platforms and fleets
uh more user-friendly to us and to the
ecosystem as well so i think that's
going to be number one okay
and number two
i you know concepts like the autonomous
for example
it's in the maturation you know we see
that
we will have some
some
more more capabilities it's going to
take more time
it's going to be less of a marketing
trick and more of a reality that is
setting upon us
but it's going to be gradual and part of
this
graduality for example you will see that
we will need to be communicating better
between us and the autonomous agent so
right now there is some autonomous
agents you can correct level two level
three
you can call it cruise control whatever
is that but we need to know how to talk
us between us humans and the
you know autonomous agent so we're gonna
have a period by which you know the next
10 years or so i would say maybe a
little bit more by which we're gonna
have to develop and treat it like
decision support system we're gonna
we're gonna
figure out how to play along our you
know smart digital assistant in our in
the car who is gonna take responsibility
on what honest conscience and
subconscious level so you can see all
sorts of development i think is going to
be fascinating coming to us in this
direction
but i think the leadership in terms of
the commercial uh incentives it's going
to be up to the sustainability and
everything else is going to drive behind
that
if you had to take a wild guess i'm
looking at my seven-year-old niece she's
going to
you know get go and perhaps i don't even
know if she will need to get her driving
license when she's 17.
what is how is her relationship with
this vehicle this mecha this mechanism
that transports her how is her
relationship with it on a consumer level
do you think is going to be different
than my relationship with my car or or
your relationship with your car the more
traditional relationship
so you know
it's a good question i'm not sure about
the time and age so you know in in
if you look at the
innovation and how we see that evolving
in the in the mobile field you know you
know there's a big difference between
you know three five years you know you
have kids that are 15 years old and kids
at 20 euros or the big difference
between them how they actually you know
play around and fiddle with the with the
mobile phone um i don't know exactly the
pace of changes that you're gonna have
upon us in the in the mobility realm in
that sense okay i don't know if it's
gonna be five you said seven years old
so in ten years she's gonna be she's
going to have a driving license you'll
be able to drive
you know i i still believe
that we will have in 10 years from now
have to have
very strong fundamental capabilities of
how to
behave socially and according to the
rules in the roads so it will not be
like launch and forget we'll not be able
to sit and say hey guys you know we
either going to get some sort of shared
mobility uh service even though it's
going to be more dominant
apparently uh and i don't think it's
going to be a matter of a decade by
which you're going to have a fundamental
cultural change by which
people will not really need to know how
to
lose the skills so to speak of motor
skills of how to you know pass a car or
how to park you know we're gonna have
some of that
but
it's gonna be how should i put it
accessorized so think about that they're
gonna be some tasks by which
your daughter or seven years old or five
years old or people that are you know
gonna be maybe 17 years or 20 years or
maybe 10 years from now
that are will not need to know okay so
for example driving on a highway it
might be the driving on a highway in
certain place in the world will be
something that will people have less
experience with because that will be
more easily turned into the autonomous
agent part so to speak okay
so think about a task that we do and
think about yourself what can be
allocated for the future what can be
allocated for the present and i think
that you
can you can fill up the gaps there
so tal biggest problems left to solve in
the space young entrepreneur
love automotives what
you know in your perspective what are
some of the most pressing and most
interesting problems that we have yet to
sort of uncover as we're going through
the sustainability transition
so i think that
there are still many
to address okay and if you look at the
at the we talked about sustainability
um
i really think that the
looking at the
source of energy
the battery is a
is a to a certain degree it's a
it can be changed very quickly so
a progress in in technology storage
technologies alternative energy
technologies
all this
will be will have fundamental changes
you know if you think about
how you manage fleets how you manage
cars when to charge how much to charge
any singular solution that can have a
difference in this can change the
behavior of of the whole industry so
there's a big potential in finding
innovation in this field literally so if
we talk about sustainable mobility
it's a it's a it's a step function if we
find any any type of innovation i think
it's worth thinking about that and
actually doing things in that but as
well as on the digital side the the path
is still very long and i think a concept
that are going to help us
build the better decision support system
on the path
is definitely
uh huge there but we don't want to stop
there
as you know vehicles are becoming
extremely complex and sophisticated
platform
and i think that
that has to be improved as well but not
only that the infrastructure play as
well i think you can
actually have a trade-off you have less
sophisticated platform but more more
sophisticated infrastructure and i think
sometimes it makes more sense
economically to think about the
infrastructure as more as more
sophisticated and i think it's under
is it's undervalued so to speak today
people look at the vehicle and i think
the future holds a lot of promise for
the infrastructure and i think there
people need to think about
tal
i just want to thank you thank you for
both these 20 minutes but but more
importantly for for the great work that
you're doing both in the in the israeli
global ecosystem and in the automotive
industry um
you know working with some of the most
interesting companies you know in the
landscape and and i just love the you
know the vision towards sustainability
and and i think a really you know
healthy balance balanced outlook on on
you know where we're headed you know
optimistically advancing but still i'm
hearing from your perspective you know
being very realistic and and being very
cognizant of the different challenges
you know on on working with the two
sides of the spectrums the sort of the
innovators and the incumbents that are
the enablers in the industry and then
how together they're shaping towards a
more sustainable future and i really
want to thank you for joining in these
20 minutes i really enjoyed it
thanks very much michael i really
appreciate your time and effort and
thanks very much for being there for for
the community and bringing the voices
out there appreciate it thanks very much
michael thank you very much
[Music]